so when i was younger around seven or
eight years old i used to have a betta
fish named bob
and he happened to be a blue colored
fish
now i've always wondered how he got his
color
so for example where his parents also
blew
did he have any siblings that were blue
so today let's try to answer
in simple terms how bob gets his blue
color
and we'll start by defining genes genes
what are genes well genes are
basic hereditary units that are well
first of all they are passed down from
parent to offspring
so i'll write past down parent to
offspring
and they also contain information about
an organism's traits
contain info about an organism's traits
so it would only make sense that since
bob is a blue colored fish
that he must have a parent or ancestor
who is also blue colored
now a single kind of gene can have many
different versions
and we call these versions alleles
alleles and these are just different
variations of a single gene
so for example there may be a gene that
provides information
about beta fish coloration so let me
draw an arrow from bob
to we'll say color gene and
one allele of this gene may lead to a
blue colored fish so i'll write here
blue color and another allele may lead
to
green coloration and i'll right here
next to blue color green color
but physically what are genes exactly
well genes are part of dna or
deoxyribonucleic acid and i know
it's a really big word so let me write
it out for us dna deoxyribonucleic
acid dna
so dna is a macromolecule or
a really big and complex molecule so
when you hear macro just think big
or complex molecule and you can also
think of dna like
a giant cookbook of genetic information
because
that's what it is it is a cookbook of
genetic
information so
here is a close-up sketch of dna and
what i'm showing here is that dna
consists of
subunits called nucleotides nucleotides
and these are represented by a's
t's c's and g's
now jeans are like the individual
recipes you can think of them
as the recipes found inside your dna
cookbook
so they are specific segments of
nucleotides within
the long dna molecule so a gene could be
from here
to here and we think of this as
a recipe but what do these gene recipes
make
anyways well many genes encode proteins
which are made of long sequences or
chains
of amino acids so i'll write here under
proteins that proteins are made
of amino acid chains and genes provide
instructions for how to create these
chains
so thinking back to how genes are like
recipes
because each gene has a different set of
quote-unquote ingredients or in this
case
a different nucleotide sequence
different genes would therefore
encode different proteins so proteins in
this example if you want to continue on
with this analogy
proteins would be like the finished
products of your recipes
remember how i mentioned that alleles
are different versions of a specific
gene
well different alleles have different
nucleotide sequences
and are therefore likely to also encode
different proteins
so i'll write under here different
alleles and draw an arrow to
different proteins so different genes
and different alleles can give us
different proteins so a blue fish like
bob
likely has a distinct allele that
encodes proteins
which give him his natural blue color or
his natural blue shade
now an organism has many different genes
which means an
organism has the capacity to produce
many different kinds of proteins
and proteins serve all kinds of
functions some of which
include growth sending messages
oh also catalyzing chemical reactions if
you have heard of enzymes before
so i'll write catalyzing chemical
reactions
and providing structure ultimately
it's the activity of these different
kinds of proteins
that help determine an organism's
physical traits just like how
proteins can determine the color of bob
the betta fish
now you might be wondering too what
genes do in the big picture
for example not all of the cells in bob
the betta fish function in the same way
right you could say that there are
different types of cells that
perform specific functions and this is
known as
cell specialization so cell
specialization
is when different cells specialize in
different functions
and each type of specialized cell
contains a unique combination
of proteins that give the cell its
specialized function
within an organism so i'll write here
that cell specialization
comes from unique combos of proteins
and it's important to note that every
cell in an
organism contains the same genes so
going back to bob here we can say that
all his cells contain the same dna and
genetic information
whether it's on his tail or in his eye
but what makes their functions different
is which subset of genes are expressed
or used to build proteins
in the different cell types so i'll
write here
all of the cells in bob the beta fish
have
the same dna and genes just different
protein combinations
so today we learned about genes which
are passed down from parent to offspring
just like how
bob the blue betta fish got his color
and they contain information about
organisms traits
so genes are parts of longer dna
molecules and
they consist of specific segments of
nucleotide bases so thinking back to
our cookbook and recipe analogy right
genes can encode all kinds of different
proteins
and it's this unique set of proteins
within each cell that gives the cell
its specific function within the
organism as we talked about
with bob the beta fish and all the cells
involve having the same dna
and genes just different proteins